so I started my journey worth mentioning
I started my my journey as a CIS Israel
largest defense and IT company um and
when you're like building a program of
how to protect the most critical assets
that you have and you're facing
basically nation state adversaries and
you're watching the battle yourself
you're understand hey this is like a
whole new level of Battlefield right you
have the air the ground military and so
on this is a whole new like cyberspace
Arena where if you understand what
you're doing and you're uh seeing how
offensive an approach our adversaries
are attacking you and you're putting the
right security controls in place and
you're able to actually stop an attack
and which brings the entire company to
the ground that is like super fulfilled
right I mean this is the essence of why
we are here
[Music]
dead blatman welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so excited to have you here
how are you I am great thank you for
having me it's really great to be here
looking forward oh dead what a what a
career I mean what an what a journey I
mean I'm just I'm I'm getting
overwhelmed just looking not only at the
places you've been at but the positions
the breth of experience from a from
coming in you know I guess more entry
levels to then being entrepreneur and
then diving into ceso and CIO roles and
some of the most fascinating perhaps
challenging but then Innovative in
futuristic areas and and so many
different disciplines so we're gonna
have a lot of fun in these 20 minutes
I'm super excited and and I have to ask
you you know who are you how you know
when you think of odad you know and
you're painting this picture who who's a
dead so I'm just a regular uh Israeli
entrepreneur
um father of three um who really had a
I've been lucky to work in a couple of
different Industries and like cherry
picking my experience from Defense
Finance and all over the place and and
came with a I think a very vast
knowledge and experience around cyber
security business
or the conjunction between them um so
that's a little bit about about me um
that's it when when does Cyber come into
your to your path so is this already
from Day Zero or whe When how when do
you start integrating cyber security as
a prime factor within your career
Journey Ah that's a great question thank
you H well actually I started my way as
a a developer and then moving to the IT
world uh and then doing kind of
international IT project at the time
were it wasn't cyber per se it was like
security now it's branded as a cyber
right and that when you know what's the
difference between security and cyber
maybe marketing does uh so I actually
started my way in international projects
uh very large scale Nationwide uh it uh
project where all of a sudden the
requirement for security came along and
now it's not enough just to have a very
unique innov
infrastructure but it also has to be
secure uh moving fast forward I
understood that more and more customers
and again I grew up uh in the defense
industry um more and more customers and
defense are usually the spare heading
security um asked for security more and
more and talked about threats and what
are the risks and all of a sudden it
became a really big thing and when
you're starting to combat and do
offensive security yourself you
understand that wow this is super
important it's such a vast area of
Technology where you actually got to
understand both code right how you're
protecting your code how you're
protecting your
infrastructure um how you understand
adversaries and how do you build a whole
security program out of it now this is a
lot of moving parts so it has to come to
kind a holistic approach how do you like
give a prot taex and and security
umbrella on the infrastructure and the
product basically that you're offering
your custom so this is what like how I
started it came from requirement then
realizing hey there's a new thing here
that we got to protect not only provide
code and infrastructure but they got to
be also secure and I'm talking about
like 15 years ago like I was younger
toer with
hair now odad your eyes are lighting up
as you are talking about about this I I
can see it
literally why what's so interesting
about this intersection so I started my
journey worth mentioning I started my my
journey as a CIS in Israel largest
defense and IT company um and when
you're like building a program of how to
protect the most critical assets that
you have and you're facing basically
nation state adversaries and you're
watching battle yourself you understand
hey this is like a whole new level of
Battlefield right you have the air the
ground military and so on this is a
whole new like cyberspace Arena where if
you understand what you're doing and
you're seeing how offensive an approach
our adversaries are attacking you and
you're putting the right security
controls in place and you're able to
actually stop an attack and which brings
them entire company to the ground that
is like super fulfilled right I mean
this is the essence of why we are here
we are here security folks we are here
to protect the company to protect the
business to protect you know the most
important assets whether it's IP and
obviously customers data and
intellectual property and all of those
so you're working a lot you're putting a
lot of Defense uh and security controls
in place you're always thinking one step
ahead of the of the adversary or what
can go wrong you got to always be on
topnotch technology understand what are
the attack vectors possible imagine like
all the scenarios possible put the right
security controls and mitigating
controls and compensating controls and
and manage this risk and when you see
this entire operations from code from
cloud product development cooperate
Insider threat there's so many elements
to building a good security program at
the end when you see add Aries are just
cannot enter your company and you are
enabler to the business basically you're
enabling the business to do what needs
to do whether it's sell bring customers
protect whatever assets and the
businesses keep on going while you're
like protecting with your own body you
know against all adversaries that's an
amazing feeling of achievement so this
is like you know what's uh driving me up
and I started my way in a defense
company where we actually build the
whole new security program with Security
operation Center which was at the time
the best I think in the world uh and we
faced with you know incident response to
attacks that we cannot detail here but
you can just let your imagination go on
things that we uh saw identified did
forensics and and basically took apart
all the attack vectors and put uh things
in place to Tech them cyber intelligence
we did a lot of research and development
around cyber security from the time that
AI was only a buzzword and machine
learning maybe was the best data
analytics at the time right uh doing
certifications for military grade then I
moved like to a whole new area from a
defense onr to an oncloud
product uh area which has its all unique
challenges and basic basically I worked
at a company called click software where
the challenge was how to put a a good
security program in order to H do the
business objective which is to get
Acquired and indeed after a year and so
we got acquired by sales
for.com and when you're a part of this
amazing you know Giant in in security
you are really seeing how Enterprises
large scale global scale companies are
managing security as scale I mean this
is a whole different bulg game it's all
different technology whole new paradigm
but how do you like protect Cloud assets
um devops teams production teams it's a
whole new concept that you have to like
shift your mind from onr to cloud and
Dev sack Ops comes in play kubernetes at
the time security you know End to End
security is a challenge moving from a
cloud company after we did the
acquisition got acquired salesforce.com
which I was there another year and I
moved to Israel largest bank bank of
with where I was there ciso and over
there you basically are learning the new
regulation around Financial Industries
when you're working Financial Industries
all of the send everyone you know wants
to attack you everyone wants to get your
funds right um so over there you're
learning a new industry of financial
industry fast forward you know when I
got the call from our CEO who said had I
have a company called fire blocks
uh we are all security top notot guys
knowing but I want someone who can take
this company to a military grade we are
a cloud Product Company and we're in the
financial industry and it seems like you
have the whole three holding grils how
about being our CIO in seesaw I simply
jumped on this and it's a great roller
coaster and fun ever since far blocks
for those who don't know what far blocks
is doing far blocks is in the crypto and
blockchain Technology basically it's a
tech company providing platform for
Secure Storage transfer of digital
assets over the blockchain it's a
product company um I think the most
amazing one with super talented
engineering security it and guys were by
the way all very security aware the
starting from the founders basically
most of the people here are very
security savvy so we started in cyber
security moving to platform company and
if you think about this when you're in
the financial industry over blockchain
which is a whole new
technology uh the threats are different
are even more
complicated because even if you think
that you know how to protect like the
cyber security space right there is a
lot of companies
who protect their cyber security space
now all of a sudden you have a new
element of hey how do you secure a
blockchain your crypto company you have
to learn a whole new um Technologies
around web 3
blockchains things that are super super
interesting whole new attack Vector that
you're opening up whole new attack
vector and it's open in some areas it's
basically a green field you have to
understand first of all I think you have
to understand that you don't understand
right and you have to learn I mean I
thought I knew everything or a lot right
when you're coming here you're talking
to the farmers talking to some of the
people here who actually built some of
the cry cryptography you realize hey you
know I got a lot to learn which is great
fun so how do you how do you protect
like your private key right and there's
a whole new technologies that were
invented in books all about the MPC or
CMP Technologies how you're dividing
your private key in order how do you
transactions without bringing them all
to a place making it jeopardized to
attacks how you do a transfer of funds
over the
blockchain okay where you got to
mitigate Insider threat mistakes because
I like other medas in the blockchain if
you put something on the blockchain it's
a
reversal once it's there you put a
transaction you put the funds over digal
assets you cannot take it back so you
better know what you're doing you better
also know that it's you opening brackets
inside your thread is a big thing over
there and so there's so many interesting
things around blockchain security which
is on top of your cyber security per se
which is a great fun and challenge I
think that we are having an amazing
security team here in fireblocks where
we are approaching cyber security in
like different vectors first for example
the depth setups okay we got to make
sure that our product is free of
vulnerabilities right we're a product
company so like every company we got to
make sure that our development uh
environment our code our Cloud
infrastructure are all free of
vulnerabilities the architecture is
secured by designs best practices that's
not enough we got to be much more you
know offensive approach it's an area
where you know you cannot fail right so
we got to make sure that you are all the
time sharp red teaming offensive back
boundy we got to make sure that you know
there is no room for mistakes here and
we are responsible for a lot of
transactions and and you know F Bloods
has led like four trillion dollars in
the last couple of years wow it's crazy
amount D you said something that really
really interested me you what you said
before was that early on you understood
and you perceived your role as on one
hand a protector of the organization
right but then you translated it to
being an enabler and what I heard from
you is that you effectively see your
role as an as enable enabling the
company to just do what it needs to do
because if you didn't exist then the
company would very quickly get
compromised and and nothing else would
matter the product wouldn't matter the
the funds in the bank won't matter and
so you effectively don't only see
yourself as a protector but you actually
see yourself as now an enabler for just
everybody else to it to actually do
their
job so being enabler is and just to put
it on the ground and not keep itting
amorphic um means that you have to
understand that with all due respect to
security the business got to exist right
and you cannot be like I've seen couple
of cisos and Mentor for some of them you
know coming with approaches like my way
or the highway okay that wouldn't scale
okay and that's not the right approach
you understand you have to understand
that the business have to exist and the
security got to go side by side and have
the right balance between security and
operations right uh making sure that the
business is running and this means that
you got to manage the risk in a very
smart way not all the time as a cesa you
will get what you want okay sometimes
you'll have a risk and it's a
negotiation between the engineering and
security team and you got to have the
this delicate balance how you're putting
the right security controls in different
place and some sometimes you will need
compensating controls to watch over and
monitor the risk while it's being
clothed okay because sometimes the the L
risk just takes time to close so this is
one thing on the other hand you have to
understand that if you're doing a good
security the customers will appreciate
meaning customers cherish trust and if
your customers will understand that
you're doing the best that you can and
you're Best in Class in security they
will feel more comfort in signing
contracts with you so as part of the
selling of new you know U new contracts
or bringing new customers security can
play a a major role we're participating
and I'm talking to ceso customers and
Prospects and once they understand what
are the great security controls that we
have here and we're standing in the
highest regulations possible much more
than in the market we have like an
internal security operation system uh
sorry ation Center that we have here in
fire blocks which others either don't
have or they're not coming to this
military great Security operation
monitoring capabilities once customers
hear that they feel more Comfort
comfortable or signing contracts with us
and putting their funds or basically
path through funds within fire blocks so
being an abler means that you have to
understand where you can contribute to
Bringing new customers and business
maybe by the way over giant product I
how of your capabilities that are being
developed inhouse and monetize it right
and on the other hand not stopping
development or features that were
promised to customers and finding the
right balance between engineering and
security this is a thin line which is
very interesting it's kind of an art
right and it takes a lot of things and
how to get there from putting controls
in the code and monitoring and code
reviews and a lot of sdlc and other
three four letters that we will not get
into right now but it's a hard work but
basically the essence you got to
understand that it's a balance between
the business objectives and security and
finding this sweet spot where everything
is still secure but you're enabling the
business to run and grow as much as it
can and this by the way also go through
regulations and understanding you know
if you're before IPO got to
understanding the highest certifications
as cryptocurrencies which are fire
blocks is standing being being always
ahead of the curve and being a leader in
this space is super
important it's so fascinating so have
you seen a shift in the perception of
this role its importance its relevance
see the seeing the you know navigating
between the thin line of security and
operations and how do you do this this
artistic dance and the trade-offs have
have you even if you look at the last
decade H what have you seen I've seen a
couple of things I think that there is
the even the terminology ciso has kind
of a different variants right so there
is cisos which are like U governance
style u making sure that you know the
company is working according to the
policies um that the documentations need
in play certificates and then there is
those who are more technology oriented
are very deep into the development code
coding process in the corporate security
making sure that the SAS are are indeed
hardened going into the details going
into the systems verifying and they are
technology leaders in what they are
doing so it's a very Balan now the shift
that I see is more and more companies
and by the way the regulation even in
the states are very supportive of this
if you look at the sack uh SEC U
regulations in the states there are
actually U pushing forward for ciso to
sit around the leadership table in
company this is because they are
emphasizing the importance of cyber
security and responsibility even not
only the CEO but also the board members
to be aware be accountable and
responsible for cisos now this adds a
whole new layer where ciso has to talk
in a language of business not only
security not only controls and we touch
this a moment to go they have to
understand the business aspects enable
the business and that's a good reason
why they need to stand uh or said around
the leadership de now if we're looking
into the future for a
second one of the roles of ciso is to be
one step ahead of the curve and that
means that you have to understand and
first of all participate you know in in
in startups open source communities got
to adopt new technologies have to be
much more efficient because you know
security is a spend so you got to do a
lot more with the existing headcount or
resources that you have so if you're
looking for example on the future TRS I
think that it's important for C to
realize that there's a whole new attack
vectors coming in and if we just take AI
for example okay we had like generation
one of fishing attack right so we have
like a spare fishing emails links
impersonating in here and person there
okay we know but we have to realize the
Deep fake in AI
Technologies and um are on the rights
and all of a sudden we got to prepare
organization raise the awareness find
technologies that if you know like
fishing attack version two is coming in
play you got to be ready for that okay
and the CIS so you have to understand
hey this is the next gen how do I put
controls in place how do I make sure
that my users are aware how do how do we
practice where do we do how do we know
that you know if far block ciso has a
long hair all of a sudden that might be
False Image or something like this we're
talking about the Next Generation in AI
we're talking about Security operation
Center for example all of the autonomous
suck and putting Bots and utilizing AI
for your efficiency for the ciso
efficiency to detect much faster um
security uh alerts analyze them in your
Security operation Center automate all
the response of like the tier one alyst
if you have a security Operation Center
in place um this is something that is uh
on the rise and a lot of companies and
startups are putting efforts on finding
how can we make the security Operation
Center much more autonomous and
automatic using those uh same
Technologies but now in the favor of
protection and not attack Insider threat
is a big thing now it was always around
it's not new but when you're working in
a in a crypto or blockchain company uh
and financial industry obviously Insider
thread is a big issue I mean how do you
identify them how do you put the the
relevant guard rails in place uh again
in in crypto if you're putting the money
on the chain blockchain it's IR
reversible so uh Insider thread is
something that uh you have to detect
smart contracts pieces of code that are
on chain and responsible for the
transactions or doing some operation
with the transactions is something that
is uh unique to blockchain and you have
to go you have to know how to find
vulnerability otherwise otherwise might
drain your wallets from from funds um so
there's a lot of um issues around the
future of cyber security and it's always
developing right it's uh this is what is
part of the F you're it's always there
you can see the adversaries are learning
themselves uh the how to attack
different attack vectors and if I have a
minute I can show you or I can bring you
an example um where we saw a couple of
adversaries that we are following and we
are keeping our eyes open all the time
for new adversaries and their attack
vectors and you actually saw them
putting payouts on uh for example
Windows operating systems and after a
couple of months they realized that it's
not the right operating system they came
back with a whole new payloads adjusted
for Max okay operate IOS operating
systems and due to the fact that we are
U just knew their attack vectors and
their threat operating the how how
they're actually doing those attacks and
the
ttps uh we actually stopped them way
before he
reaches so it's a all new cat and mouse
uh vector just got to be ahead of the
curb all the time and it's a great area
to be first or technology in business
and being really valuable to the company
that you're R and it sounds like you're
having a lot of fun yeah indeed and I
think that what's awesome is that coming
from an engineering background and
developing background to business and
entrepreneur right you were CEO of
companies I mean you you were
responsible not just for and and sure
they were also in the cyber security Dom
domain but but ultimately you're
responsible for the bottom line for the
for financial projection so you
understand ultimately that it does come
down to you have to progress and move
forward and develop the right products
and business but then but then having
the experience of going to the in the
defense industry and the and the
financial industry and and click
software and then and then real Banking
and then new Banking and and so it
really feels like you're like you're
living through these incredible
Transformations that we're in h and and
like you mentioned you know we're we're
approaching a future in which there's so
many new attack vectors that require you
to play and even faster more creative
Canon Mouse game and not just from a
software perspective but from the
employee Behavior perspective like in
the context of deep fix right there's a
lot of human engagement that's going to
take place in the in I think in this
next phase of of AI and fishing uh and
uh and we we're all here to have fun and
to do something really meaningful so uh
H thank you for this time odad this was
just aesome much I had a blast thank you
for thank you you so much
[Music]